faisons du bruit
Jeremy a l'air de merde en
voyant la baie médicale pour un examen Je
me verrai au bar pour prendre un verre Rencontre saoudienne
ouais non pas d'équipage
allons-nous sortir de celui-ci
Je suis jayla tu ne devrais pas avoir d'accélérateur
bienvenue  à je ne sais pas ce qu'est un
tapis de bienvenue j'ai besoin de votre aide si nous n'arrêtons pas des
millions la vie est en jeu ce dont nous avons
besoin est une diversion viens avec moi
c'est ainsi que la distraction à propos de la musique
j'aime les rythmes et bien crier tu
sembles conduit  dites à ceci votre nouvel ami
ici de cette façon pour moi il nous aime stock
comme Sony rencontrer des millions de vies sont entre
vos mains je crois en vous capitaine
je vais détruire votre genre
je pense que votre honneur estime l'humanité
par le D ensemble pour imaginer ce qui va trouver
des extraterrestres déterminés à nous tuer
c'est les os spirituels
vous faites une bonne équipe je crois que nous nous
accrochons à quelque chose
voulons y retourner
du bruit
Jim tu ressembles à de la merde  voir l'
infirmerie pour un bilan de santé je me verrai au
bar pour me rafraîchir à propos de ce que tu lui as dit